badria martov says she was overwhelmed
by headaches fatigue and vomiting for
days
she's now been diagnosed with
hemorrhagic fever
and is receiving medical treatment at
this hospital in the southern iraqi city
of anastria
we and our neighbors have cows and sheep
but the livestock don't show any
symptoms i probably got the disease from
our barn or our neighbour's barn
the province of the car has recorded the
highest number of cases among 13 other
regions
most of them are farmers or butchers
hemorrhagic fever is a viral tick-borne
disease that is transmitted to humans
through the bites of infected ticks or
by direct contact with the blood or
tissues of infected animals
subsistent farming is common in villages
across iraq
animal burns are usually located near
houses
so family members often take care of
their livestock
officials have conducted sterilization
campaigns in several provinces including
the capital baghdad
life is stuck on burns are sprayed with
cyber methylene solution
an anti-tick pesticide
we spray everything the ground the walls
the holes in the walls the ceilings as
well as the parts of the animals that
are potential areas for ticks to live
including their skin and fur
catalan sheep are the most potential
carriers of the virus
on monitor the slaughtering is common
here
so the health ministry has urged people
to buy meat only from licensed
butcheries
climate change in iraq has helped the
virus to evolve its genetic
characteristics from strained viruses to
substrate that's how it's become more
resistant it usually starts worsening
from mid-march every year that's the
breeding season for ticks and newly born
leeches which find their way onto
animals skin
hemorrhagic fever is part of the family
of viruses that includes ebola
lassa
antivirus and yellow fever
it has been reported in iraq since 1979.
veterinarians say the virus is likely to
be eliminated
by the rising summer temperatures
but there are concerns unhygienic
butcheries could give breeding ground
for the virus as more animals are
slaughtered during the upcoming muslim
festival
of
atha
al-jazeera
baghdad